Known as the father of modern fantasy is epic tales of legends and Law.
I've been enjoyed by millions of people all over the worlds devoured and popular
books and adapted for Hollywood blockbuster films.
Unbelievably Bright.
He was a distinguished university professor,
poet,
historian,
and experts,
linguist as a trials.
He even made up his own languages for pure fun.
He gave us a complex and fence for creatures,
including hobbits,
orcs and elves sat in a prehistoric middle laugh.
Some theorize that is made up.
Worlds are symbolic of his country's past power struggles influenced by his
devout Roman Catholic faith or simply the genesis of his personal experiences.
In any case,
there is no denying his glorious imagination and his rightful place amongst the
greatest writers of all time,
but who was the creator of the hobbies and the Lord of the Rings?
Well,
today on biographics,
we explore the life of Jane are talking.
Yeah.
Before
bank clerk after talking and Mabel Suffield welcomes their son into the world
via English couple moved to South Africa.
Here,
Alpha had high hopes of advancing his career and providing a comfortable life
for their budding family.
John Ronald rule known as Ronald to most was born in Bloemfontein South Africa
on January the third 1892 not long after another son Hillary.
He was born competing,
the talking family,
talking his childhood in Africa.
It was cut short when his mother decided the boys would be better educators and
then native England's at the age of three Talkin and his mother and younger
brother left for their homelands.
Well,
Arthur stayed behind to settle the business.
He was planning to join them but never meters falling ill and dying of these
severe brain hemorrhage,
a complication of rheumatic fever on February the 15th 1896 at the time the
spread of disease and contagions were fears and to travel took many weeks if not
months off.
His body was laid to rest without his family by his side.
Having spent just a small fraction of his early years in Africa,
talking had very few memories from that time.
However one tail persists,
but the facts remain uncertain according to this story.
The then toddler talking stumbles upon and was bit by a baboon spider type of
tarantula in the garden.
Talking,
ran,
screaming,
and it isn't as immediately snatched him up and just suck the venom out from the
wound.
Talking later said he could remember a hot day and running and fair through long
dead grass,
but the memory of the tarantula itself,
faders and he sad that the incidents left him with no special dislike of
spiders.
Still fans and armchair psychologists to like speculate whether the tarantula
influenced the presence of man eating spiders talkings later fictional works
well back in England's Mabel in the boys settled with family in the West
Midlands first and King Seeth Ethan.
Then in cell hole on one hands,
and especially in the city of Birmingham,
the West Midlands was urban,
dark and industrial.
On the other hand,
it was the idyllic English countryside with lush green trees and a corn mill in
the rural hamlet of [inaudible] between the ages of four and eight talking lived
across the street and within 300 yards.
If the sat whole mill and Mosley bog,
he spends many hours that playing with his younger brother and being chased by
the Miller's son,
whom the boy is nicknamed the white.
Oh,
the Shi'a Tompkins imaginary land of hobbits was inspired myself.
A hole in the hobbit.
He writes of Bilbo Baggins running as fast as his fairy feet could carry him
down the lane past the great mill across the water and then on for a mile or
more tokens.
Mother homeschooled the boys at first to teaching the young Tolkien botany ans
the basics of Latin talking could read fluently by the age of four and to write
soon after he loved drawing landscapes and trees,
but his favorite studies where those involving languages.
Later he would attend King Edward's school in Birmingham,
which proved to be the perfect breeding ground for the boys is natural curiosity
and developments of linguistics.
Talking was an exceptional student.
He was capable of easily mastering ancient and modern languages including Greek,
Latin,
Spanish,
old English,
old Norse,
Gothic,
and finish the boy.
He made up his own languages including early variations of elvish.
Once featured in his writings asking Edwards,
he made a number of close friends and formed a semi secret society.
Let's enjoyed drinking tea and critiquing each other's literary works.
They called themselves TC bs,
which stood for the tea club Barrovian society.
Despite the earlier loss of his father.
Life of the [inaudible] was generally happy until two events altered the course
of his life.
In 1900 his mother decided to convert to the Catholic faith,
this ball to move left and Mabel and her son's estranged from both sides of the
family and in the fall.
Laos talking experienced isolation,
loneliness,
and poverty.
Following his acceptance and some Catholic church talking remained devout in his
faith for the rest of his life.
He has also been credited with being partly responsible for bringing another
famous writer and friends.
Cs Lewis spect,
Christianity.
Tragedy.
Then struck talking again in 1984 when his mother was diagnosed with diabetes.
A sure death sentence in that time,
sadly,
Mable died in the same year on November the 14th talking was 12 at the time.
Fortunately for Tolkien and his brother Hillary,
that Catholic priest,
Father Francis Morgan stepped in and it became their guardian and made sure the
boys received everything they needed both materially and spiritually.
Talking mess.
His eventual bright brass when he was 16 and she was 19 they were both orphans
and lodges at a boarding house run by a woman named Mrs. Faulkner,
the two group funds of each other and a friendship developed and then as it
happens with teenagers,
the patter came too close for Father Francis.
His liking.
He was horrified as ward was courting a Protestant women and to believe the
relationship was a distraction from talking school work for other Francis for
Bates,
talking to see your corresponded with Edith until he was 21 this was a
devastating blow to talking,
but he obeyed the order.
When his birthday approached,
he wrote to his love and his proposed marriage.
Her reply was heartbreaking,
but offered a glimmer of hope.
She was engaged to another man,
but his latter,
NATO reconsider.
Edith agreed to meet talking on January the eighth 1913 at the train station in
Shelton.
They walked and talked for hours and Edith accepted tokens,
marriage proposal,
breaking off her prior engagements.
You just converted to Catholicism and the couple married on March the 22nd 1916
[inaudible] was 24 years olds and a few months shy of deploying to the western
front in all.
That's it to his son,
Michael.
Years later talking expressed admiration for his wife's willingness to marry a
man with new job.
There's more money and to know prospects except the likelihood of being killed
in the great war.
Talking was a true romantic and Edith was his muse.
He wrote to her,
oh,
how was raven a skin clear her eyes brighter than you have seen them and she
could sing and dance talking.
We're so mad for if he created the fictional power of star crossed lovers based
on their romance Lithion daughter.
If the Alvin King of Dory F and Barron a mortal man,
they fall for each other.
When baron discovers Lithion singing and dancing and a glade.
Yet that love can never be since baron is destined to die.
Alas,
disapproving father,
the King Sends Darren on the task.
He knows the mat and cannot complete the full story of Leith.
Ian and baron was left unfinished during [inaudible] lifetime,
but it served an important backstory and the hobbit talking son Christopher
later published Lithion and baron is a chapter in the saga,
the Silmarillion Edith and Toki and enjoyed a long and happy marriage to each
other and they had four children,
John Francis,
Micheal,
Hillary,
Christopher,
John,
and Priscilla.
Marianne [inaudible] was a devoted father and his loved his children,
often making up funds for stories for them from 1920 to 1942 at Christmas time,
talking illustrated letters to his children,
introducing new characters such as the north polar bear,
snow man and others.
Three years after his death,
these intimate stories were published as letters from Father Christmas by the
Tolkien estate
believing he was in his own words,
a young man with too much imagination and little physical courage.
Talking did not rush to join the British military when war broke out.
Instead,
he returned to Oxford where he had achieved a first class degree in June of 1915
Tolkien was busy working on poems and his invented languages at this time.
Eventually though,
talking enlisted as a second leftenant in the Lancashire Fusiliers and was sent
to active duty on the western front just in time for the battle of the Somme,
also known as the Somme offensive.
The Battle of the Somme remains one of the bloodiest military battles in
history.
It lasted for long months and on the first day alone,
British troops suffered over 57,000 casualties in total.
Over a million men lost their lives,
including 420,000 British soldiers fighting in the great war,
talking witness the horrors of trench fighting and lived in deplorable and
sanitary conditions.
It was hell on earth for Tolkien and his comrades who stood by as their friends
suffered and died them.
They spend their days and nights with little relief and endured infestations of
lice that feasted on their flash.
As a result,
talking came down with trench fever,
a major medical problem of world war one so severe with a licensed captain
staying with talking's units.
Later recalls we dos down for the night in the hopes of getting some sleep,
but it was not to be,
we no sooner lay down than hordes of lice got up,
so we went round in the medical officer who was also in the dog house with this
equipment and t gave us some ointments which he assured us would keep the little
bricks away.
We anointed it ourselves all over with the stuff and to gain lay down in great
hope,
but it was not to be because instead of discouraging them,
it seems to act like a kind of hoarder of the little beggars went at their feast
with renewed vigor,
sick and is unable to fight.
He's talking left the battle front to recover in a Birmingham Hospital in
November of 1916 through 1917 and 1918 talking had bouts of the illness and he
spent time in remission doing service at home and at various camps talking most
likely escaped death on the battlefronts precisely because he became ill,
sadly all but one of his close friends,
including those from the tcbs perished in the war as a writer.
This tragedy of loss and firsthand experience in battle provided.
Talking with a keen sense of awareness from the unpublished,
the book of loss tails talking,
writes in huts full of blasphemy and smart or by candle light and bell tense,
even some down in dug outs on the shelf in the hobbits,
the battle of the five armies.
It's thought to draw upon talkings wartime experiences as well as the dead
marshes and black gauge of mortar in the Lord of the rings.
On November the 11th 1918 the armistice was signed,
which marks the end of World War One.
Duncan was appointed assistant lexicographer Ron,
the new English dictionary,
also known as the Oxford English dictionary in 1918 but stayed on the job for
only a short while.
In the summer of 1920 he accepted a post as a reader with the University of
Leeds Leeds.
He taught and collaborated with other authors,
continued writing the book of loss tails,
constructed languages,
and founded reading and social clubs like the Viking club.
This was an undergraduate club for Stevens who had an affinity for old Norse
Sagas and drinking.
Yeah.
In 1925 talking that finally received his professorship at Oxford.
The Rawlinson man's Bosworth professorship,
Anglo Saxon talking,
was right at home in academia and fit in remarkably well with the predominantly
male culture.
He reveled in the lectures,
research and exchange of ideas with students and fellow professors.
Talking did not publish many scholarly articles yet he was extremely
influential.
One lecture worth mentioning altered the modern study of the old English epic
tale,
Baerwolf and twist first delivered in 1936 in Baerwolf,
the monsters and the critics talking argued the monsters,
Grendel,
Grendel's mother and the Dragon,
or not merely extraneous to the narrative,
but should be a focus of study.
Talking believed critics,
but too much emphasis on the historical elements of the tail.
Instead of looking at it as a work of art as Oxford,
talking to friends and colleagues,
cs Lewis,
best known for his fantasy series,
the chronicles of Narnia,
the two men bonded over their shared love of mythology and it's began meeting
regularly for a glass,
a joke,
and to criticize each other's poetry.
The meetings were so enjoyable and useful,
they invited others to join.
The informal group known as the inklings,
eventually grew to 19 members and to the mass once a week late at night,
sometimes not wrapping up until two or three o'clock in the morning as well as
the practice talking shared manuscripts of works in progress with the inklings
and received energetic feedback from the group.
Among other ratings.
Talking brought original poetry sections from the Hobbit,
excerpts from the notion club papers and each new chapter of the Lord of the
rings.
There is little evidence to support the suggestion by some that the men had a
more spiritual purpose to them.
Meetings,
the inklings continued to meet regularly for 19 years.
Together with talking and Louis,
some of the more distinguished members of the infant's included Neville
Cockatiel,
Hugo Dyson,
Owen Barfield and Charles Williams.
In 1945 talking changed as chair at Oxford do the Merton professorship of
English language and literature.
He held this position until his retirement in 1959
one hot summer day in 1928 professor talking was grading exam papers,
which he described as soldiers drying.
He came upon a blank page and without thought wrote down in a hole in the
ground.
They lived a Hobbit,
us,
what was a hobbit and why did it live in the grounds?
Well talking,
you need to define the answers to these questions.
He said later,
names always generate a story.
In my mind I thought I'd better find out what hobbits were like.
Then injury,
talking fashion,
the dive headlong into the creative process and concocted a tale to tell his
younger children and share amongst the inklings.
In 1936 and incomplete copy of the hobbit wound up in Susan diagonals,
hands and employee of the publishing firm,
George Allen,
and when recognizing the stories,
potential dagnall convinced talking to finish it and complete it,
she presented it to her boss.
He then tested it out on his 10 year old son who gave us a raving review.
Ours was published one year later in 1937 and it was an immediate test.
In fact,
it was so successful that the publisher asked Toking if he has any similar
stories today.
Since the first publication,
the hobbit has sold more than 100 million copies around the wells and has been
translated in over 50 languages.
So you might be wondering,
well,
what makes the hobbits so endearing?
For one thing,
it lacks female characters and it is not,
nor has it ever been politically correct.
It is also a very long tail with poetry and unlike other children's fiction,
does not have a central child figure for whom young readers can easily identify
with.
Although the protagonist Bilbo Baggins is only a little hobbit,
so he does kind of acts like a surrogate child.
Talkings colorful descriptions of middle earth and it's complex characters,
goblins,
elves,
orcs,
wizards,
dragons,
and hobbits of course,
are richly portrayed and for all the fantasy writers you came after talking
hardly any can say their wells were not,
at least in part,
influenced by the hobbits.
But what set the story apart is the depth of emotion and moral courage talking
weaves into his heroic fiction.
There are examples of this throughout the Hobbit,
including the death of Dwarf leader,
Thorin,
Okin shields.
There's also build those internal struggle to do what's right,
betraying his friends while they tried to reclaim the lonely mounds in from
Smok,
the dragon bill by fields and obsessive greed has overtaken Thorin and when
builder finds the Arkenstone the greatest treasure of all,
he decides to first hide it and then give it to his friends procedures to be
used as a bargaining chip in the ends.
Bilbo exposes himself and confesses because after all,
they are friends.
After talking's publication of the hobbyist,
he presented portions of the Silmarillion including incomplete stories of
Lithion and baron to Stanley and when hoping for a warm reception,
but his reader Phelps the stories when not commercially publishable,
they simply contains too much poetry.
Talking was disappointed of the news,
but soon found himself busy writing the sequel to the hobbyist talkings opus.
What would become the Lord of the rings?
This was first published in three parts,
the fellowship of the ring,
the two towers,
and the return of the king between 1954 and 1955 it took him over a decade to
write these books and wind son who was by now an adult,
was heavily involved in pushing a temperamental talking to finish the books,
thinking it would be a relatively unimpressive release and they lost the from
the publishers grossly underestimated the Lord of the rings.
Public Appeal,
true is had mixed reviews from damning to glowing and everything in between.
The BBC adapted it into 12 condensed episodes,
elevating its popularity further.
Then in the mid 1960s a pirated paperback version was released,
which caught the attention of American readers,
sort of cults then developed based on the new founds popularity of fantasy
literature and talking was made a rich man.
He was not entirely happy though,
even if he was flatus,
partly because rumors circulators of party going culture readers ingesting LSD
and reading the Lord of the rings and indeed some overzealous fans who talking
referred to as lunatics.
We're calling his home and demanding to know if Frodo has succeeded as his
quest,
the hobbies and the Lord of the rings certainly receive all the glory,
but talking authored a number of other articles and essays during his lifetime,
including the monsters and the critics and other essays.
One middle earth related work,
the adventures of Tom Bombadil editions and translations of Middle English works
such as the [inaudible],
so gay when answer or Feo and the pal and stories,
the Emram,
the homecoming of band,
Roth band,
Roth's son and stories,
the Emram,
the layer of outro and Itron Pharma Giles of Ham leaf by Niggle and Smith of
which a major following his death,
the letters from Father Christmas were released by the Talkeetna state and later
son Christopher saw to edge that his father Silmarillion and a number of other
incomplete writings under the title of unfinished tales of Numa norm.
Men's middle f published after his retirement from Oxford talky and moved to
Bournemouth.
And on November the 29th 71 the love of his life.
Edith died nearly two years later on September the second 1973 talking followed.
There's a final testament to their love and at talking's instruction,
they were buried in a single grave on their tombstone.
Baron is engraved under his name and Lithion.
IPS under Edith
talking shall remain a celebrated literary figure through the ages as his life
work continues to inspire the fantasy genre around the world.
His characters and places have become the namesake of various street names,
companies,
mountains,
pants and objects.
There are even asteroids named after Bilbo Baggins and talking himself in
England that all seven blue plaques that commemorates places associated with
talking,
talking was made a commander of the British empire by Queen Elizabeth in 1972
and z holds a number of other achievements and awards,
including an honorary degree from the National University of Ireland and the
University of Legion 1954 and the Lucas award for the best fantasy novel for the
Silmarillion in 1978 and the two thousands talking ranked on bbcs greatest
Britain's list and the Lord of the rings was the Uks best love novel in 2003 and
his ranks among the hundred greatest British novels in 2015 Tolkien was placed
sixth on the list of the 50 greatest British writers since 1945 published by the
Times in 2008 in 2009 he was listed as the fifth top earning dead celebrities by
Forbes from 2001 to 2003 new line cinema release the Lord of the rings as a
trilogy directed by Peter Jackson.
The series was extremely successful and won numerous Oscar's from 2012 to 2014
Warner brothers and new line cinema released the Hobbit,
a series of three films based on the Hobbit book,
the first in 2012 the Hobbit,
an unexpected journey.
The second in 2013 the hobbit to the desolation of Smaug ans the final
installment in 2014 the Hobbit,
the battle of the five armies talkings middle earth is surely the gift that
keeps on giving and it is quite amazing considering he wrote it all in his spare
time.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.